Every "Fast and Furious" film has provoked
squabbles among fans, and those squabbles
have only gotten bigger as the franchise has
grown.
From casting decisions to plot twists, these
are the times the "Fast and Furious" franchise
outraged fans the most.
Every "Fast & Furious" movie is a micro time
capsule of what was hot in popular culture
at the time of its filming.
The original film was in the dead center of
a time when light wash jeans, Hollister shirts,
and massive aftermarket spoilers were a significant
part of the culture.
The early films were so beholden to trends
that they made an entire movie without the
original cast just to cash in on the surging
popularity of a Japanese racing style.
The casting of Dwayne "The Rock" Johnson was
an unquestionably smart decision, but will
also serve as a glimpse of a time when the
wrestler-turned-actor was coming into the
peak of his box-office powers.
"I thought so."
Other casting decisions didn't receive the
same sort of love as Johnson's.
Fans absolutely lost it when they realized
that rapper Iggy Azalea played a small part
in"Furious 7" and they took to the internet
to vent about it.
Though the part was inconsequential and the
film was still a hit, some people admitted
it made them properly angry.
Glasgow is a working-class city, full of the
exact kind of folks that would delight in
the "Fast" gang's constant heists from greedy
companies.
However, being a worker means having to get
up in the morning, and the shooting of "Fast
and Furious 6" made that more than a little
difficult.
According to reports from the Daily Record,
locals were furious about two weeks of nighttime
filming that included loud, car-based stunts,
explosions and gunfire.
They took umbrage at the fact that they had
not been warned of the night shoots until
right before they began, and complained repeatedly.
Glasgow's Film Office painted a different
picture, saying that the film crew behind
the movie had given residents ample warning.
At least the stunts looked good on the big
screen.
While most franchise fans would be ecstatic
at the idea of a new film, a number of people
in the "Fast" fanbase thought it was crass
when the franchise opted to continue after
the death of a core cast member.
Given the focus on family, quite a few fans
were angry when "Fate of the Furious" was
announced as the eighth film in the series.
Continuing the series without Paul Walker
didn't sit right with people who had followed
the franchise from small-scale drag racing
caper to international gang of car-driving superheroes.
Some fans claimed they would never see the
film, while others simply worried on social
media that carrying on after Walker's emotional
sendoff would cheapen the ending of "Furious 7."
Still, "Fate" was a hit, and a ninth film
was announced after its release.
"Fate of the Furious" gave fans more reasons
to be angry than Paul Walker's absence.
The plot of the eighth installment in the
series pitted Dominic Toretto against his
surrogate family, which the trailers made
clear.
Since the movies all stress the importance
of created families and friendly bonds, and
Toretto has put his life on the line countless
times to save his crew, Dom turning his back
on that and even threatening to kill his friends
sparked anger when the trailer was released.
Fans wondered aloud why the franchise would
take such a turn, particularly in the wake
of the loss of Paul Walker in the real world
and the loss of friendly characters like Han
within the "Fast" universe.
For certain viewers, it felt like the end
of a beloved story.
"You lost the minute you interrupted my honeymoon."
Of course, it was later revealed that Dom's
turn in "Fate" was only part of a blackmail scheme.
By the end of the film he'd returned to his
family, defeated the bad guys, and even made
time for a cookout with all his friends.
Han didn't need to be avenged, but fans couldn't
have known that.
Since "Furious 7," we've been operating under
the assumption that the fan favorite character
died at the hands of Deckard Shaw, the mercenary
who arrived in that film to avenge his brother's
own defeat in "Fast and Furious 6."
Shaw's quest for vengeance began with Han,
whose seemingly fatal crash all the way back
in "Tokyo Drift," was revealed to be the same
crash that launched Deckard's fight against
the Toretto crew in a cliffhanger scene from
"Fast and Furious 6."
Then came "Fate of the Furious," and the revelation
that Deckard Shaw was not only walking free
after Han's death, but actually becoming part
of the Toretto gang.
He even landed his own spinoff alongside Dwayne
Johnson's character, Luke Hobbs.
Han may not have been the most important member
of the Toretto crew, but his death was still
supposed to mean something, and letting Shaw
just get away with it inspired what's become
known as the "Justice for Han" movement among
fans, something that will now be addressed in "F9."
With the "Fast" universe continuing to expand,
some of the sniping over the films is coming
from inside the franchise.
Following "Fate of the Furious," series star
Tyrese Gibson tore into the production of
"Hobbs & Shaw," the first movie outside of
the franchise's main timeline, saying that
the film was not worth splitting from the
official series.
In a now-deleted Instagram post after the
spinoff was released, Gibson tore into the
film's box office numbers and its attempt
at, quote, "breaking up the family."
He also offered the opportunity for "Hobbs
& Shaw" stars Dwayne Johnson and Jason Statham
to return for "Fast 10" to give, quote, "true
fans" what they wanted.
Gibson's comments only served to stoke reports
of on-set feuding between himself, Johnson,
Statham, and Vin Diesel.
At the moment, everyone seems to be happy
with the direction of their careers, but who
knows what the future might hold as the main
"Furious" series reaches its end.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movie franchises are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.